speaking of robots that operate in the
real world
let's talk about self-driving cars
oh
okay
because you do you have built robotics
companies you're one of the greatest
roboticists in history and that's not in
space
just in the space of ideas
we'll also probably talk about that but
in the actual
building and execution of businesses
that make robots that are useful for
people and that actually work in the
real world and make money
you also sometimes are critical
of mr elon musk or less more
specifically focused on this particular
technology which is autopilot inside
teslas
what are your thoughts about tesla
autopilot or more generally vision-based
machine learning approach to
semi-autonomous driving
uh these are robots they're being used
in the real world by hundreds of
thousands of people
and
if you want to go there i can go there
but that's not too much which there is
let's say they're on par safety wise as
humans currently meaning human alone
versus human plus
robots okay so first let me say i really
like the car i came here in here today
which is
a
2021 um
model
mercedes e450
i am impressed by the
machine vision
sonar other things i'm impressed by what
it can do
i'm really impressed
with
many aspects of it and and i'm
um it's able to stay in lane is it uh oh
yeah it does it does the lane stuff um
it uh
you know it's it's looking at on either
side of me it's telling me about nearby
cars or blind spots and so on yeah when
i when i when i'm when i'm
going in close to something in the park
i get this beautiful gorgeous top-down
view of the world i am impressed
up the wazoo of how you know
registered and metrical that oh so it's
like multiple cameras and it's all
versions together to produce a 360 view
kind of 360 view you know it's
synthesized as though it's above the car
and it is unbelievable
i got this car in january it's the
longest i've ever owned a car without
digging it um so it's better than me
for me and it together are better so i'm
not saying technology's
bad or not useful
but here's my point yes
it's
it's a replay of the same movie
okay so maybe you've seen me ask this
question before
but um
when um
when when did the first car go over 55
miles an hour
for over
um
over 10 miles
on a public freeway with other traffic
around driving completely autonomously
when did that happen
is it was it seem you in the 80s or
something
it was a long time ago it was actually
in 1987 in in munich um a munich there
at the bundesvar yeah um
so they they had it running in 1987.
when do you think and elon has said he's
going to do this
when do you think we'll have the first
car
drive coast to coast in the us
hands off the wheel hands off the wheel
feet off the pedals coast to coast
as far as i know a few people have
claimed to do it 1995. that was tommy i
didn't know about oh that was the code
yeah uh they didn't claim did they claim
a hundred percent not a hundred percent
not 100 but but and then there's a few
marketing people who have claimed 100
percent since then but my point is that
you know i i what i see happening again
is someone sees a demo
and they over generalize and say we must
be almost there well we've been we've
been working on it for 35 years that's
demos but this is going to take us back
the same conversation with alpha zero
are you not
okay i'll just say what i am
because i thought okay when i first
started interacting with the
with the mobile eye implementation tesla
autopilot
i've driven a lot of car you know i've
been in google self-driving car since
the beginning
um
i thought there was no way before i sat
and used mobileye i thought they're just
knowing computer vision i thought
there's no way it could work as well as
it was working so
my model of the limits of computer
vision
uh was
was way more limited than the actual
implementation of mobile eye i was so
that's one example i was really
surprised i was like wow that was that
was incredible the second surprise came
when tesla threw away mobileye
and started from scratch
uh i thought there's no way they can
catch up to mobile eye i thought what
mobile i was doing was kind of
incredible like the amount of work and
the annotation yeah well mobile i was
started by amazon structure and and used
a lot of traditional you know
hard-fought computer vision techniques
but they also did a lot of good sort of
uh like non-research stuff like actual
like
uh just good like what you do to make a
successful product right scale that all
that kind of stuff and so i was very
surprised when they from scratch were
able to catch up to that
that's very impressive and i've talked
to a lot of engineers that was involved
this is
that was impressive uh and
the recent progress especially under um
well with the involvement of andre
capathy
the what they were
what they're doing with uh the data
engine which is converting into the
driving tasks into these multiple tasks
and then doing this edge case discovery
when they're pulling back like the level
of engineering
made me rethink what's possible i don't
i still you know
um
i don't know to that intensity but i
always thought it was very difficult to
solve anton was driving with all the
sensors with all the computation i just
thought it was a very difficult problem
but i've been
continuously surprised
how much you can engineer first of all
the data acquisition problem because i
thought
you know just because i worked with a
lot of car companies
they're so a little
a little bit old school to where i
didn't think they could do this at scale
like aws style
data collection so when tesla was able
to do that
i started to think okay so what are the
limits of this
i still believe
that um
driver like sensing and the interaction
with the driver and like studying the
human factors psychology problem is
essential it's it's always going to be
there
it's always going to be there even with
fully autonomous driving
but i've been surprised what is the
limit especially of vision based alone
how far that can take us
um so that's my level is a surprise
now
okay uh can you can you explain
in the same way you said like alpha zero
that's the homework problem that's
scaled large in his chest like who cares
go with here's actual people using an
actual car and driving many of them
drive more than half their miles
using the system right
so
yeah they're doing well with with pure
vision without your vision yeah and you
know
and now no radar which is i suspect that
can't go all the way and one reason is
without without new cameras that have a
dynamic range closer to the human eye
because human eye has incredible dynamic
range and we make use of that dynamic
range
in it's uh 11 orders of magnitude or
some crazy number like that
the cameras don't have that which is why
you see the
the
the bad cases where the sun on a white
thing and the blinds are
in a way it wouldn't apply in the person
i think there's
a bunch of things
to think about before you say this is so
good it's just gonna work
okay
um um
and i'll come at it from multiple angles
and i know you've got a lot of time yeah
okay let's
have thought about these things yeah i
know you've been writing a lot of great
blog posts about it for a while before
tesla
had autopilot right so you've been
thinking about autonomous driving for a
while from every angle
so so a few things
you know in the u.s
i think that the
death rate from
motor vehicle accidents
is about 35
a year
which is an outrageous number
not outrageous compared to covert deaths
but you know there is no rationality
and that's part of the thing people have
said engineers say to me well if we cut
down the number of deaths by 10 percent
by having autonomous driving that's
going to be great everyone will love it
and
my prediction is
that if autonomous vehicles kill more
than 10 people a year they'll be
screaming and hollering even though 35
000 people a year have been killed by
human drivers
it's not rational
it's a different set of expectations
and that will probably continue
so there's that aspect of it
the other aspect of it is that
when we introduce new technology
we often change the rules of the game
so when we introduce
cars
first
you know into our daily lives we
completely rebuilt our cities and we
changed all the laws yeah jaywalking was
not
an offense
that was pushed by the car company so
that people would stay off the roads so
there wouldn't be deaths from
pedestrians getting hit we completely
changed the structure of our cities and
had these foul smelling things you know
everywhere around us and you know now
you see push back little cities like
barcelona is really trying to exclude
cars
etc
so
i think that
to get to self-driving
we will
um
large adoption
it's not going to be just take the
current situation take out the driver
and put the same car doing the same
stuff because the end case is too many
um
here's an interesting question
how many um fully autonomous
train systems do we have in the us
i mean do you count them as fully
autonomous i don't know because they're
usually as a driver but they're kind of
autonomous right no
let's get rid of the driver
okay i don't know
it's either 15 or 16. most most of them
are in airports
okay um there's a few that go about five
two that go about five kilometers out of
airports yeah um
uh when do when when is the first
fully autonomous
train system for mass transit expected
to operate fully autonomously
with no driver uh in the u.s city
it's expected to operate in 2017
in honolulu
it's delayed but they will get there but
by the way it was originally going to be
autonomous uh here in the bay area i
mean they're all
very close to fully autonomous right
yeah but the getting the clues is the
thing and i have i have i've often gone
on a fully autonomous train in japan um
one that goes uh out to that fake island
in the middle of tokyo bay i forget the
name of the and and
and what do you what do you see when you
look at that what do you see when you go
to a fully autonomous train in a in a in
a
um an airport
it's not like regular trains there's at
every station there's this double set of
doors um so that there's a door of the
train and this door off the the um
of the the platform yeah um
and it's really visible in this japanese
one because it goes out in amongst
buildings
the whole track is built so that people
can't climb onto it yeah
so there's an engineering that then
makes the system safe and makes them
acceptable i think we'll see similar
sorts of things happen
in the us what surprised me
i thought
wrongly
that we would have
special purpose lanes on 101
in the bay area
the the leftmost lane
so that it would be normal for
teslas or other cars to move into that
lane and then say okay now it's
autonomous and have that dedicated lane
i was expecting
movement to that you know five years ago
i was expecting we'd have a lot more
movement towards that we haven't and it
may be because
tesla's been over promising by saying
this you know calling their system fully
self-driving
i think they may have been gotten there
quicker by
collaborating
to change the infrastructure
this is one of the problems
with
long-haul trucking um being autonomous i
think it makes sense on freeways um at
night for the trucks to go autonomously
um
but then is that how to get onto and off
of the freeway what sort of
infrastructure do you need for that
do you need to have the human in there
to do that or can you get rid of the
human so i think there's ways to get
there but it's an infrastructure
argument
because the long tail of cases is very
long
and the acceptance of it will not be at
the same level as human drivers
so i'm
i'm with you still and i was with you
for a long time but i am surprised how
how well how many edge cases
of machine learning and vision-based
methods can cover
this this is what i'm trying to get get
at is um
i think there's something fundamentally
different with uh vision-based methods
and tesla autopilot and any company
that's trying to do the same
okay well i'm not i'm not going to argue
with you because you know i
i
we're speculating yes but i i you know
my gut feeling tells me
it's going to be
um
things will things will speed up when
there is engineering of the environment
because that's what happened with every
other technology i'm a bit i don't know
about you but i'm a bit cynical that uh
infrastructure which relies on on
government
to help out
in these cases um
if you just look at infrastructure in
all domains it's just a government
always drags behind on infrastructure
there's like there's so many just well
in this country
sorry yes in this country and of course
there's many many countries that are
actually much worse on infrastructure oh
yes there's not many much worse and
there's some that you know like
high-speed rail the
other countries have done much better i
guess uh my question is like
which is at the core what i was trying
to think through here and ask is like
how hard is the driving problem
as it currently stands so you mentioned
like we don't want to just take the
human out and duplicate whatever the
human was doing but if we were to try to
do that
what
how hard is that problem
because i used to think is
way harder like i used to think it's uh
with vision alone it
it would be three decades four decades
okay so i don't know the answer to this
thing i'm about to pose
but
i do notice that on highway 280 here in
the bay area which largely has concrete
surface rather than blacktop surface
the white lines that are painted there
now have black boundaries around them
and
my
lane drift system in my car would not
work without those black boundaries
interesting so i don't know whether
they've started doing it to help the
lane drift whether it is an instance of
infrastructure
following the technology but but it
my car would not perform as well without
that change in the way they paint the
line unfortunately really good lane
keeping
is not as valuable like
it's orders of magnitude more valuable
to have a fully autonomous system like
yeah but but for me
lane keeping is really helpful because
i'm busy at it but you wouldn't pay
10 times like
um the problem is there's not financial
like it doesn't make sense to to to
revamp the infrastructure to make lane
keeping easier it does make sense to
prevent the infrastructure oh i see if
you have a large fleet of autonomous
vehicles now you change what it means to
own cars you change the nature of
transportation i mean but that that for
that you need
uh autonomous vehicles let me ask you
about waymo then i've gotten a bunch of
chances to to ride in in a waymo um
self-driving car and they're
i don't know if you'd call them
self-driving but well i mean i i wrote
in one before they were called waymo
yeah still at x so there's currently
this was a big another surprising leap i
didn't think it would happen which is
they have no driver
currently yeah in chandler in chandler
arizona and i think they're thinking of
doing that in austin as well but they're
they're expanding but
although you know and i i do an annual
uh check-up on this so as of late last
year they were aiming for hundreds of
rides a week
not thousands
and
um there is still no one in the car but
there's certainly
safety uh people in the loop and it's
not clear how many you know what the
ratio of cows to safety people is
i it wasn't
uh obviously they're not 100 percent
transparent about this no none of them
are 100 transfers
but
at least the way they're
i i don't want to make definitely but
they're saying there's no tele operation
um
like they're i mean
okay and and and that sort of fits with
with um youtube videos i've seen of
people being trapped in the car yeah
by a red cone on the on the street
and they do they do have rescue vehicles
that come yeah and then a person gets in
and drives it yeah
but isn't it incredible to you
it was to me to get in a car with no
driver and watch the steering wheel turn
like for somebody who has been studying
at least certainly the human side of
autonomous vehicles for many years and
you've been doing it for way longer like
it was incredible to me that this was
actually could happen i don't care if
that scale is a hundred cars this is not
a demo this is not this is me as a
regular the argument i have is that
people make interpolations from that
interpolations that uh you know it's
here it's done
um you know it's just you know we've
solved it no we haven't yet
and and that's my argument
you